it's gonna be a whole new vibe that
brings people together
i'm just unlinking your change
well you only got three chords i
will make them sound like a million
[Music]
bucks
i don't know that it was a surprise
because i think we all knew
but the thing that i was astonished by
is
how strong she was uh
in that she was able to both be a mother
at such a young age and continue her
career all the way through
i for me that's almost an impossible
feat
uh but she did it and did it with grace
um and did it with excellence uh there's
something very specific
about the way she was able to keep
forging through and changing and
moving with the music and i i knew i had
it in my head
about the type of music she was able to
do i just didn't realize
completely how vast the catalogue
is and how different it is from each era
so whether you're thinking about i know
the 50s and there's a song called
rockabye
which is really really cool and very 50s
or you're thinking about
respect that we all know or you're
thinking about uh
um new york waiting with george michael
and you're thinking about sisters are
doing it for themselves but then you
think about a rose with lauren hill
she just seemed to have this really
wonderful way of moving
through the era moving through the time
and moving through music and still
managing to make it very much herself um
or while raising a family
which to me astonishes me completely
it was really inspiring actually as as
someone who is a musician and is
starting to come into her own
um space and making her own music and
and
figuring out how to find a space within
it and that allows
for ownership i think the thing that was
really
inspiring was how she was managing to do
that
finding her voice which then led to her
being able to be
bold enough to ask for uh the credit for
the work that she was doing
which meant that she was able to be
celebrated in the in the right way
um it's an inspiring thing to learn to
do and and to learn the ways in which
she was able to stand up for herself
because
sometimes it was a quiet storm sometimes
it was raging and
like to like meander through all of
those ways in which she
found a way to plant herself um
was really special yeah
there's one song that was both well you
know okay uh there was one song
that was moving but more challenging
than i thought it would be
and it's a song called never grow old we
did um
just an edited version because the
actual version i think is about 9
to 12 minutes long so we did like a
shortened version of it it's called
never grow
old and it's part of the amazing grace
documentary record um and the reason it
was challenging is because it has no
time signature
it's like free time so and aretha has
this beautiful way of being able to
to sing a phrase that should be
eight beats long and make it 16 and
stretch it out with the breath that she
takes with the weight she takes
um and i having to learn that there's no
there's no touch points there's no okay
so there's four beats here and that's
four beats there or
that song that line ends here and it
starts here because there's no
there's no time signature so i was like
it took me some time to really learn
that but there's something about getting
into a song that feels really
challenging because finally you can let
go of the semantics of it you can let go
of the
the process and really just feel it and
the sentiment is that there is a place
that is not
here that we might not know until we
pass on
that where you can well you can live on
forever
where you can why you never grow old um
and i just thought it was a really
beautiful
moment to to sit and sing um we sang
that
live on set and it just felt good um
and then the other was uh you're all i
need to get by
just is it's a beautiful song um
and i had three wonderful backing
vocalists who were working with me that
day
it just felt like a really it was a good
day i remember doing that it was a good
day
and the song felt good to sing and she
her
version of that song is so
sweet and and triumphant
that i i just it it really moved me when
i was able to do it
you gonna remember her name aretha
the number one thing i learned about her
well i mean
basically the overall like her backstory
and like
i'll say this again how she turned her
heartbreak into song and
basically like what she went through as
she was also powering through
being the queen of soul that she is and
one thing i want them to take away
is her genius and how
how she did turn her heartbreak into
song and how she
how she overcome so many hard moments
and she just kept
rolling through in like she kept she
never gave up
i tell other people this too i challenge
anybody to come out of
the deep south sharecropping where your
your daddy gave you an
ultimatum your stepdad he gave you an
ultimatum
either you the the the pulpit or the
plow
you got to decide right now and he chose
the plow and his father's father kicked
him out of the house
and he had to sink or swim and to go
from
seeing what folks in the 20s and the 30s
that were black that saw that saw their
family relations dragged and beaten and
burned and hung
and shot and to see that and to still
as as he instilled in his his children
especially in aretha the
no matter how bad it gets we're going to
keep going
and keep going until we achieve our
goals and
the there is there is a uh there's a
high cost for that
living there's a high cost and there was
no psychiatrist and psychologist for
black folks to sit on the on the couch
and and talk about
you had to figure it out and there was
uh the people who were the most
vulnerable
were the uh at that time for you know
that that suffered the most
i believe were the women and the
children black women and black children
caught her from every side
and uh and still i rise so
the the genius is that it took her seven
years
and she still she kept going she didn't
give up after three or four or five
or six she she was the most talented
person
in the world could sing anything could
read could hear something one time
and play it and sing it but she couldn't
get a hit record
because she had to figure out what her
sound was which was different than
barbra streisand which was different
than
uh than nancy wilson it was different
than
you know james brown and and uh uh
um for roberta flack so it just took her
a minute and she would not give up she
was a dog with a bone
and that is you know for as far as i'm
because that's genius
that it doesn't happen one time it may
not happen until the thousands
thousands time and even if it don't
happen i'm not giving up that to me is
genius
there's a cost for for for that talent
and that
you know that and the cost was the her
relationships her relationships with her
her you know her father relationship
with her husband relationship with her
children everybody had the
relationship with her sisters you know
they went through it um because
she was so supremely gifted but the how
she got there you know that she was the
favorite everybody knew that
and uh there's a cost for that uh in the
internal
family politics as everybody knows
within their own families with their own
dynamics it's
there's a cost to that and they had to
pay for that cost every
you know throughout their lives
[Music]
well we didn't hear really we didn't
really hear much about
litter aretha's life like we don't the
media doesn't see that
so like being able to see
what she went through as a kid was a
little different from what i
like studied and kind of looked at like
i looked at her interviews i listened to
her songs and stuff but that's
way different because we didn't see her
childhood on the screen
so i i think i prepare myself based off
of her
older self but also i try to connect
um like scenarios that i may have went
through
to her scenarios to her scenarios and
what she went through
it's easier for a woman to be the help
made of a king
than it is for a man to be the helpmate
of a queen
don't let that queen thing go to your
head i'll let that clean thing go
wherever i wanted to
you know uh i can't speak for ted
but um but yeah jerry lexler
uh you know immediately
uh recognized it and uh um
you know they they it was not
going at first um but they came to
really uh um appreciate each other
and um they came to a
pretty deep understanding and that
relationship grows over time as you can
see
if you watch the whole thing um you know
and it was uh
a lot of respect you know and uh respect
that
producers weren't giving the artist
much less uh african-american women
artists at that time so you know
yeah and i think yeah you know and and
ted's
ted's angle was coming at it one you
know ted was very attracted to
female singers right and um
so that was that was very much you know
what what he was into and and he
recognized her talent and he loved that
music
do you know what i mean and i think he
was also one of those people that wanted
to be
loved it so much always wanted to be
romantically involved in that you know
when you see him earlier he's with don
washington
you know so this is an individual who
very much
gets married to the town do you know
what i mean he he literally
falls in love with the talent of it all
[Music]
well yes right like uh you know i think
i think i'm an actor right
so like uh you know i try and do things
that
wait you haven't heard i the rumor is
that i'm an actor
oh dude it's all over the internet you
need to go
is it mom don't go actually don't go
don't go on the internet
all right well all right well until i
see the interview uh
blogs uh and the rotten tomatoes score
i'm going to call myself an actor
and then uh and so and so i think this
was a
this is this was me going in a different
space
uh you know same same for david and i
you know i don't really
watch any of his work but i assume this
is different from what he usually does
um and it was just it was just an
opportunity you know what i mean i think
sometimes it's not even familiar with my
work as the as
as the irritable bowel in the irritable
bowel syndrome
syndrome yeah i remember i think you and
antonio banderas did a thing together
for uh for tylenol and uh
and and yeah so this was just a it was a
chance to stretch different
uh muscles and and to tell a different
story you know
i i come from theater a lot and so
theater you get to do
a lot more crazier uh things
and so i think this is like kind of an
opportunity for the audience to see
some things that i've i've done in my
career but probably not on this level on
this public stage
you know give her credit for
you know not necessarily coming in and
you know making a whole speech about it
but just
effectively taking over the production
you know and
uh um you know not in a uh
way she just sort of did that was
intuitive to
to her and um and
and you know before what i'm saying like
right people right time and then
uh jerry and his whole team were clearly
like
amenable to it and they they're doing
what's best for the
for the for the song for the music you
know
so was she so is he and you know the
best art is
is often collaborative and you know i
think it's a
good example of that time to change it
and i want to keep changing with it
you got to disturb the piece when you
can't get no peace
[Music]
it was relatively easy strangely enough
because i just kept telling it to myself
genius jeans you know it's like if you
say um
uh if you walk outside and say i'm
looking for a dog i'm looking for a dog
you know i'm looking for a cat i'm
looking for
you know that's what you're gonna be
focusing on so if i i
continually repeat it to myself we are
telling aretha franklin story through
the lens of genius
and so let us focus on those moments
where she
did uh she she demonstrated her genius
as we understand it
where she alchemized her pain into sonic
gold where she brought
different peoples together for a common
for a greater good
where she created things that will
endure uh
for long past her her lifetime uh where
she
did things that people thought you're
crazy to try that you know
and she succeeded um so i just
continually focused on those moments
she has a wealth of them what a life she
lived
when she was recording uh a recording
session
there was a pizza box on the piano and
they moved and she's like
put it back because it changes the sound
of the piano
those kinds of things she did all the
time she was a musical genius
well sure but it's again we go
way back to episode one where it's 1967
it's in alabama and alabama at that time
was run by george wallace and george
wallace's wife you know segregation now
segregation forever those wallaces
and when she walks in the studio and
it's a
group of white not just white people
white
men let's just remember she's a black
woman walking into a studio in muscle
shoals alabama
greeted by white men who are there of
course to play wonderful music with her
but there's there's a lot of proving
that
we have to do we as women we as black
american women there's a lot of proving
that we still have to do
um and it does help when someone on the
other side
right uh can vouch for us and that's
we can call it whatever we want but i
call it reality
that's life in the real world you know
what i'm saying um
so that's how that's how we operate it's
called community you know
if i know you and i can vouch for you
gene and you know me you can vouch for
me and
you know that helps move the that helps
move
uh things forward
[Music]
first of all we wanted the story to lead
and the songs to follow
so we didn't want it to be uh what do
you call a jukebox biopic
kind of thing that's that was and
because again we're looking at
aretha franklin's life through the lens
of genius not through
turn on you know her hits okay but
secondly
the the just an obvious uh plain fact we
couldn't get the rights to some of the
songs
you know and so we did what
black american people have been doing
from the beginning we make a cake
out of what we got you know what i'm
saying and
it's a beautiful opportunity for us to
focus on story
we get plenty of the hits and we get a
lot of lesser known gems too
and sometimes you know it's weird when
your ear
sometimes you hear is i heard that song
before whatever
and then the story goes on but these
songs that you don't hear often like
border song you're talking about the
pizza box moment
how many times have we heard her sing
that song not not often enough
and you really lean in and listen to the
words in the context
of the civil rights of progressive
people's movement
you know so it gives us an opportunity
to really hear things
[Music]
you